so the supreme court killed the private
employer of acts mandate as we talked
about uh on friday but that doesn't mean
that there are no more private employer
vax mandates because now some employers
can are choosing to keep them anyway
even though they have no excuse to no
reason to
they have no reason to because they're
not being forced to do it also because
there's no as we've discussed there's no
rational scientific basis for it when we
know that vax and unvaxed alike spread
the virus so there's just no
there's there's
nothing to grab onto here in terms of a
reason for a vax mandate
you have no foundation for it
but employers are doing it anyway
and elijah schaefer is a great podcast
over host over at the blaze has this
screenshot reportedly from an email
from carhartt
to to their employees and this is what
it says it's gone viral today it says
carhartt associates uh many of you have
asked how the recent supreme court
decision on the osha mandate for large
employers will impact our associates so
we want to provide some clarity
the ruling does not change carhartt's
mandatory vaccination program which went
into effect on january 4th as you know
we have extended vaccination deadline
for both our cv and madisonville
associates to february 15th
this state also remains in fl in effect
we put workplace safety at the very top
of our priority list and the supreme
court's recent ruling doesn't impact
that core value we in the medical
community continue to believe vaccines
are necessary to ensure a safe working
environment for every associate and even
perhaps their households
which doesn't make any sense at all of
course so carhartt they're still going
to have their vaccine mandate
um
here's what i'll say about this
i think these companies need to be held
accountable for this
but who holds them accountable
well the consumers need to do it so i
put the onus on us primarily as
consumers
on myself
i i have been a carhartt customer in the
past
as an avid fan of bass pro shops you
know you go there and you're gonna find
plenty of carhartt um
that's where i put the onus
so i i think that and i do that
much more than i put the onus on the
employees and this is an important point
because i think sometimes we're a little
bit too blithe and casual about just
declaring that employees should quit
under these circumstances i hear that a
lot i hear that in conservative media
for example well you should just quit
that's really easy to say
it's easy for me to say
we don't have a vaccine mandate here our
employer is one of the ones that went to
supreme court to fight this
so i don't have to worry about it
um i'm getting a paycheck and i'm
feeding my kids and and i'm bringing you
know the bacon home to my family so that
so it's i'm good
so it's really easy for me to sit here
and say well you should quit your job
you out there watching this right now
just quit quit right now today
go home and explain it to your wife
later
uh you'll be fine
now if you can quit your job
then great then uh you know if you can
and you decide to quit your job in
protest of something like this to stand
up for your rights then i think that's
fantastic i think it's i i admire that
but i know that i'm a father i have a
family
and that's my first responsibility
and i put that responsibility over
everything and everyone
really i mean over conservatism over
liberty
over my country
i'll choose my family over my country
i'll choose it over literally everything
and everyone except god himself
that those are my values
and what that means is that if i'm in
this position
if i was put in the same position let's
say someone a carhartt's in
i'm not going to leave my job in a huff
all at once
and make my children go hungry
might be that might be what you want me
to do for your own sake but it's not
what i'm gonna do
because i have my family and i care
about them more than i care about you
and i care about them more than i care
about your values
so what i would need to do if i was in
this position and i wanted to leave and
i would want to leave but i would need
to secure another job first
and that takes time
um it's not something that i can afford
to do just leaving the job all at once
going out in a blaze of glory to prove a
point
that's not fair to my kids
okay so i can go home feeling good and i
could say to my kids well i took a stand
today
well that's great dad but how are we
going to eat tonight
that's my first responsibility is to
make sure my kids are eating
not to make a point about vaccine
mandates
not that the point isn't important but
it's not as important as my duty as a
father
so
does that mean that we should just lay
down
am i advocating that not at all
i'm putting the onus on the consumer
because as consumers
we we could crush this
we have that ability much more than the
employees do
because the other thing is as an
employee you quit
again i admired if you decide to do that
but if you do they're just gonna they're
gonna replace you they're gonna find
someone who who will
who will cooperate with the vaccine
mandate and they'll just replace you and
that's it
and continue doing what they want to do
you can't replace consumers though
at least they're a lot harder to replace
so
as consumers
if we say to carhartt you know rather
than pointing to the employees who have
families to feed and saying you all
should quit
dad just quit
how about we make the decision not to
buy carhartt
until they reverse this tyrannical
uh senseless irrational
immoral mandate
because here's the great thing we have
nothing at stake
we don't sacrifice anything
i mean literally nothing you sacrifice
carhart okay just buy a jacket from a
different company
you're not gonna freeze to death you'll
find some company that doesn't have a
vaccine made it where you can buy a
jacket
plus you probably already have 15 of
them in your closet anyway
so
we could do that but here's what we do
as consumers
you know we we sit back and say all you
should quit
and then we continue to patronize
these same companies
we could bring these companies to their
knees
by using the power we have as consumers
and it costs us nothing to do
so think about the sacrifice of leaving
your job
when you have a family to feed
versus the sacrifice of just not buying
crap from one company and buying it from
another instead
who who's making the greater sacrifice
who should we
be pointing to
and expecting them to you know
expecting more from
so that's what that's what gets me i i
um
especially a company like carhartt
they're
i would guess the majority of their
employees are going to be more of the
conservative
blue-collar sort of persuasion
okay there's not a lot of
prissy leftists in in los angeles or san
francisco or manhattan walking around
carhartt
[Music]
so we could put an end to this
we could
[Music]
if we choose not to then that's our
fault don't blame the employees for that
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated